foreign
[Music]
life was like a box of chocolates
you never know what you're going to get
I know that of course is Tom Hanks I
wonder if he's seen that scene a time or
two it's Forrest Gump in the iconic 1994
movie the same name we welcome you back
to CBS morning let's talk about Tom for
just a second he's won two academy
awards for best actor he's been awarded
a presidential medal of freedom the only
person in the room who can say that he
is starred in dozens of movies over his
40-year career including Catch Me If You
Can Apollo 13 Toy Story I love Sleepless
in Seattle myself now the acclaimed
actor is sharing everything he knows
everything about making movies and the
people who do it there's a new book out
it's called the making of another major
Motion Picture Masterpiece I like that
word it's a fictional account of making
a film from conception to release and
Tom Hanks the author is in studio hi Tom
Hanks I felt like I was just going
through the Grid on DirecTv
no matter what channel there was some
90s movie with me this guy's ever seen
it seen it know how don't recall much of
that one but Tom that's interesting
because in this book Ren Lane one of the
main characters she's flipping through
and she sees a movie that she's in and
she stops and watches exactly exactly
now then if like we're in Lane he stops
on a movie that she hates yes and she
sees herself in a scene that she loathes
yes she had to do it that might be the
only time I stop on one of my movies oh
watch what went wrong in this look how
terrible I was wondering if you do that
but listen this is the thing I've never
seen anybody do this before guys in the
acknowledgments he goes or the opening
goes for all the actors in the cast and
every member of the crew Tom I've never
seen anybody thank every member of the
crew and what I know what we know
sitting here is without the crew you
have nothing and in this movie in in
this book rather you're talking about
how every job matters when you're making
a movie that's what I thought there's a
moment that comes where a single Cog in
the Machinery has not had time to repair
or Garrett makes a mistake and guess
what you are waiting for that for that
moment to come the the pressure I think
could be back breaking on anybody yes
who has to make sure that what is up on
the set is necessary now that can also
mean an actor who hasn't really thought
through the moment or a director who
hasn't really who freezes or what have
you or a lens that is not in the kit
that needs to go on the camera but the
crew the crew goes through everything
that you do say for example and I've
made I've done enough night shoots and
after a while there's nothing you know
night shoots are actually how the
Communists used to torture dissidents it
would make them shoot at night in the
rain a love scene in which the whole
movie really and so you're trying to do
this over and over again until three
o'clock clock four in the clock in the
morning and the only way you're going
home is when the Sun starts rising and
you hear the Cox crow
that means you actually get to go home
but you talk Tom you talk about The Good
the Bad and the Ugly including a very
difficult difficult movie star okb is
his name this guy is so obnoxious such a
jerk breaks all of the rules and you
said I can relate to him I find that so
hard to believe please explain well okay
okay B in this case is a little full of
himself which happens he actually thinks
he's a bit of the of the Walk
because he's the star of what is now
going to be his third movie that fills
you with the type of hubris that is not
good for anybody and he himself might
not realize what he's going through but
Bill Johnson the director of the movie
says I need this guy in this movie for
this he's got this and there's a ton of
I just saw an example of it when I was
operating the TV there are people who
just naturally have a cognizance when
you come in here yeah and that is Money
in the Bank it is panned gold it's the
coin of the realm and you'd be amazed at
how often organizations and movies will
put up with the most insane behavior
from somebody but Tom I'm talking about
you I'm talking about you you said that
you would behaved that way that's what I
want to know you have been an obnoxious
jerk on a moon seriously oh yeah I've
been the guy who says why can't I wear
sunglasses
I think the guys should wear sunglasses
in this scene come on look cool come on
man look you can do it that way but what
if I say the line like this I love you
baby
let me wear sunglasses and the DB comes
up and says uh well we're just going to
lose your eyes
yes
the producer says Tom will have to take
the glare out and that's 250 000 in post
and okay okb says Okay no Okay B just
keeps him on and says let me do it once
with him let me do it once again it's
all wasted you you're speaking about
these moments on the set and you talked
about mistakes happening and in the book
you write about serendipities Strokes of
good luck even some disasters that may
happen wife while filming but that would
ultimately lead to a great movie like do
you have an example of that because I'm
curious I will tell you that uh on the
move on a movie that I that is on the
grid that I made one of those films made
with uh Mr Spielberg we showed up on the
set of Saving Private Ryan and the sun
was in the wrong place literally uh the
he could not shoot what he wanted to
shoot that morning because he showed up
and the son was he thought the sun was
over here was actually over there and if
the sun placement is key to how dramatic
yes uh it's like it's literally God's
God's gaffer God is your gaffer and you
have to feel it and so what he did was
he just took a walk around the set and
10 minutes later he said uh we're going
to shoot this through Jeremy Jeremy uh
is going to grab the little uh uh sniper
scope and we're going to do this we're
going to do the whole thing through
there so his entire I mean he told me
what he was going to do with this Scene
It was thrown away and Serendipity said
we're going to have to do it a different
way and you do it a different way and if
you you know if you have the great
collaborative process right there
you still get to examine the theme of
the movie no despite where the sun is
all right yes you clearly love this
collaborative process you you I mean the
book really is a love letter to it for
all the stress that is involved the
cracked vessels the human error the
mistakes at one point you mentioned a
character says they're surprised and not
everyone in the movie business doesn't
knit for sanity it's that difficult but
talk about why you love it I've heard
you call it a a bridge a movie is a
bridge over a vast body of water what do
you mean
uh when as a person who as a young when
I was young and I'd see some movie
like you're like Duel at Diablo or
something like that all right come on
said I I can't imagine a better way of
spending two hours and haven't come see
this movie my life is actually expanded
because I was involved in the story of
what these people were and that is the
bona fide art of the Arts and Sciences
of Motion Pictures we can be moved by
Opera we can be moved by a short story
that we read we could be moved by a
painting in a museum or sculpture
but the active Parts is that
participatory process of being in a
movie is you are transported from your
seat into a character in that film
you're actually a participant you're
you're engaging you're you're watching
what goes on and you actually think well
what would I do in the same circumstance
and the making of a movie
um I was a very young actor and Vincent
Dowling of the Great Lake Shakespeare
Festival was a came into guest direct
the Cherry Orchard Anton chekhovs at
Cherry Orchard and at the very first
um read through he said we're all here
for one reason and that's the that's for
and that's for fun because work in the
theater is more fun than fun and I said
that is exactly
page 97 making movies is more fun than
fun well what's not fun right now is a
writer strike can you give us your take
on that they've got a really good case
it seems the entire industry is at a
Crossroads and everybody knows it the
the the the what the financial motor uh
has to be completely redefined and there
is some degree of pie here that is going
to have to be equitably distributed by
the people who are responsible for the
content not the folks who make the deals
for the content the folks who actually
make it and first up is the writers we
do not have scripts without writers it
all starts with the written word and up
next is the directors we do not have
filmed stories without directors and the
actors are coming up as well so so there
is going to have to be some sort of sit
down and for the common good of the
story The Arts and Sciences and The
Business of show yes uh like minds are
going to have to come down and and be
Equitable and we all believe it or not
some some type of win-win situation yes
we all hope that this doesn't last long
the other thing that's fun about you
they call you an American treasure and
I'm sure you hate that but honest to God
Tom I don't know anybody we we call this
Tom Hanks Tuesday I don't know is that
every Tuesday Tom Hanks yeah it is
next Tuesday but you and Rita also have
so much fun the video of you guys at
Bruce Bruce's concert oh my Lord yeah my
by the way who knows who knows his
lyrics better than me I've been
I've been streets for an awfully long
time I know I thought that was so fun to
see all you guys oh you can't help it
you can't you yeah it's great you know
and and we were in Spain yes and uh you
know it's big in Spain oh he's they sell
a lot of Records in Spain yeah so what's
he's like their own marriage huh a long
happy marriage what's the key to it and
keep it short so I can say the title of
your book okay you got to marry the
right person for the right reason there
you go there you go uh the book is
terrific she says the same about you Tom
well I'll take it anybody in any
creative field will be inspired they'll
laugh exactly will want to do more of
what they're doing uh it's a great read
the book is called the making of another
major Motion Picture Masterpiece John
can I just say one great line today
one Gate line curiosity fuels your
passion carries you if you lose either
you're done that's true do that so
that's why it could just keep doing this
as long as you wake up in the morning
that's I feel it is true money also
counts and CBS yes deals some products
that may make your day a little bit
brighter a little bit better but Tom
sheets of your local weather Karen fell
today Tom